President Trump is now arriving in
Norfolk Virginia we don't have those
live pictures to bring to you just yet
but we will momentarily as soon as we do
in the meantime let's bring back our
medical panel of experts they are going
to answer some more of your questions
that you have been submitting to us all
morning long again let's welcome Fox
News medical contributor and family
emergency medicine practitioner dr.
Jeanette Nashua and medical director of
infectious disease prevention at
Ascension Via Christi dr. Maggie Hagen
thanks to you both for being with us dr.
Hagan the first question we'll throw
over to you it comes from viewer
Christopher Diaz who says with testing I
know we can't test everyone with no
symptoms for the virus but will it be
possible to test everyone for the
antibody so that those people can go
back to work
that's a good question we believe that
people who are infected with code 19
will develop an antibody to the virus
that will be protective how long that
protection will last whether whether it
will be a few months or a few years we
don't know but the ability to measure
that antibody would certainly be helpful
to know who has been infected because as
you know many of the people that are
infected don't have symptoms that bring
them to medical attention so if we had
that antibody test that would be helpful
there are some very preliminary data
looking at antibodies and as you may be
aware even studies looking at using
antibodies from people who have been
infected as treatment for those who are
currently battling the disease so a lot
of work is being done regarding
antibodies and we would be hopeful in
the future that that testing would be
made available doctor Nashua we have a
question from viewer Ray Sanders who
says if you happen to get kovin 19 would
using the nebulizer help your issue with
your lungs or will it make the situation
worse
so my patients for example who have
asthma and who tested positive for kovat
they have expressed me and I have seen
improvement in their oxygen level in
their Oh to set with albuterol inhaler
x' and nebulizer treatments but the
problem is when you use a nebulizer
machine you could be aerosolizing the
virus and it could spread in the room
you could potentially make other people
ill so you have to be very careful and
keep that in mind if you're gonna use a
nebulizer machine to help with your
breathing to help with your asthma to
treat the shortness of breath that we
commonly see then you want to use it in
one room of the house of where you are
so it we don't spread viral particles to
other people because that is a concern
we're gonna take we are taking a live
look there for our viewers at home at
Air Force one president Trump has just
landed in Norfolk Virginia he's about to
deplane we'll keep an eye on that for
you in the meantime dr. Hague and I'm
gonna come back to you we've got a
question from Donna Gilbert who says is
it true that you should avoid ibuprofen
Aleve and aspirin if you get Koba 19
that's a good question I keep hearing
about this yeah there have been a lot of
discussions about ibuprofen over the
past couple of weeks and some mixed
messages regarding that there were
concerns that it perhaps could make the
viral infection worse and in fact some
countries even came out with a warning
against using that the World Health
Organization came out of the statement
on the 17th of this month saying they
were looking into the issues regarding
ibuprofen but the very next day they
came out with a statement saying that
they didn't have any data that suggested
you should not use ibuprofen
that being said to treat the symptoms of
fever and body aches you might consider
using acetaminophen because we believe
that that is supporting the symptoms of
kovat okay so maybe acetaminophen um dr.
Nashua want to get through the next
question to you this comes from viewer
named Nadine s Colonia she says I am
having a baby in July and I'm getting
really nervous I'm worried about of
bringing a baby into all of this quick
note on that it sounds like World Health
Organization who's also said they don't
know a whole lot about in utero
transmission they suspect it's not
happening what do you know about it sure
so we saw nine cases I read about nine
cases in China with nine moms who gave
birth and there was no fetal maternal
transmission of the virus to the newborn
baby there was one case where a 30 hour
old baby tested positive for
a virus but did very well and recovered
very quickly and had no complications
but first of all congratulations on
having a baby the best way to protect
yourself and to protect your baby is to
protect yourself follow the CDC
guidelines of hand-washing social
distancing staying hydrated taking your
prenatal vitamins those sorts of things
and the good news is you're gonna be
giving birth in July in the summer so
hopefully the heat will diminish the
amount of cases and you won't have to
worry as much yeah definitely a question
at least in my friend group with so many
people expecting and new moms a lot of
women are asking what does all of this
mean for us not a lot of information out
there sadly but thanks for bringing us
you know what we do know at this moment
dr. Hagen and dr. Nashua thanks so much
for your time we appreciate it